[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
ISAAC METCALF: In
this video, we'll
be discussing Goodie Bag
7, or crystalline defects.
The objectives are to
visualize zero dimensional, one
dimensional, and two
dimensional defects
in crystalline materials.
You'll need a double-sided
strip of adhesive,
two Plexiglas panels, and
500 1/16th-inch metal beads.
First, pull off
the protective film
on the top of your
acrylic sheet.
Take four pieces of
double-sided tape
and put one piece on each of
the edges of the acrylic sheet.
Then carefully put your balls
in the middle of the square made
by the four pieces of tape.
Finally remove the film on the
top of the other acrylic sheet
and put it on top.
When you're finished, you
should have a completed defect
modeling kit.
CAROLYN JONS: Now that
you've built your model,
let's use it to visualize how
material processing impacts
the number of defects
visible in a crystal.
When looking at our
original crystal,
you can see several defects.
These are a vacancy,
line defect,
and grain boundary defect.
Material processing can lead
to both increases and decreases
in the number of
defects in the material.
A process that leads to an
increased number of defects
is extrusion or rolling,
because when we extrude or roll
a material, we force the atoms
to go into certain places
and those aren't necessarily
the most energetically
favorable states.
Let's look at our
model to understand
how material processing leads to
an increased number of defects.
When we shake the model,
we're able to add defects
to the system.
As you can see now, our
model has an increased number
of vacancies, line defects,
and grain boundary defects.
Other material
processing methods
allow for a decrease in
the number of vacancies.
One possibility for
this is annealing.
When we anneal, we
heat the material up,
and then we cool it slowly and
allow the atoms to move back
to their more favorable states.
To illustrate annealing,
let's tap gently
on the side of our model.
As you can see, the number
of defects in our material
has been substantially reduced.
In this Goodie Bag, we
were able to visualize
some of the defects
seen in many crystals,
and we were also able to see
how processing conditions impact
the number of
defects in a crystal.